- Do I look like Queen Amidala?
Doo doo!
Now I'm Amidala, right?
- I was really excited to hear about the
Covergirl collection, if only because it
allows us fangirls to get a little bit
more nerdy-ness into our purses
and into our bathrooms.
- It's no longer just like, "Hey look,
a Barbie line!" it's
like, "Hey, Star Wars."
- [Offscreen] Okay, let's do this!
- This is definitely like a cloudy,
metallic gray, Palpatine skin gray,
Millennium Falcon gray.
- Oh, got it on my tooth, because
that's why I don't wear makeup.
- Nope, nothing special. It looks off.
- It's pretty opaque on my arm,
it's very metallic and shiny.
- I look like I was stranded on Hoth.
- You'd have to wear a base
and layer this over it.
- I guess if I was gonna
give this color a name,
it would be like, Tauntaun Innards.
- [Offscreen] Lilac.
- Like the skies of
Coruscant, I don't know.
Can't the sky be every color?
- Once again, metallic, kind of.
Not really for my skin color, but
let's see, maybe I'll be surprised.
- It's a little splotchy,
but, you know what?
I could totally make this work.
- I definitely wish
they had names, though.
Like this one, is 100% Mara Jade.
- I'm gonna go with Jar Jar Binks.
- These are all metallics,
I've noticed so far, so hopefully
this one is metallic too otherwise
I'll be, I'll be disappointed.
- I feel like I'm applying
some sort of like, honey.
- Looks like an autumn sunset on my lips,
when I would much rather look like 3PO.
- Okay, this is super pretty.
- This is almost to par with some of
the other metallic lipsticks that I own.
- I feel like it just blends
in with my skin color.
- It's cool, it's metallic,
definitely needs a base, though.
- Obviously I'm gonna name it C-3PO.
- It's gold, it's like
the suns of Tatooine.
- Like, Palpatine's red
guard, in that one movie.
And then his guard, like went away,
and we never saw them again,
but they were pretty cool.
- Reds can be kind of tricky.
- Oh this is pretty, I actually
really like this color.
- Wow, this is not going on nicely,
I am not allowed to wear red.
- The other thing about metallics,
is it's basically glitter.
- Oddly, I like this.
This could easily be named, like,
Bloodstripe, or Slave Leia.
- Darth Maul, that's it's name.
- I was gonna say purple was
gonna be like, Mace Windu's lightsaber
because this is purple.
- I wanna call this like, Senator Amidala,
after her purple costume
that I love so much.
- Halloween is coming up,
I love wearing super dark colors.
- Oh man, this is so dark.
- It doesn't really go on smoothly.
- It's gonna be a pretty color,
once I finally get it in.
- I drew a little outside
the lines, oh god.
- I'm gonna call it Alderaan.
- Okay so now we're
moving onto the mascaras,
there are ten different sayings,
but there are only two
different kinds of mascara,
so water-proof and not water-proof.
- "I feel the good in you,"
that's a little dirty.
- "May the force be with you."
- "Indeed you are powerful," it's like
you wake up in the morning, put it on,
and go take on the world.
- These all could have been lightsabers,
so there could have been like a neon blue,
a neon red, a neon green, a neon purple.
(lightsaber noises)
- If you want to collect 1-10, do it,
because if you guys are real nerds,
you will collect all the things.
- This is actually really, really good.
- This is a good mascara.
- I can see in my youth, of loving
to collect stuff, I would be like,
"I need all 10 of these
or someone's gonna die."
- I like that you're
targeting us nerd girls,
I wish you had more
colors for people like me.
- It's cool just to know that they're
marketing something for female fans.
- I am just proud to know that
fangirls are being represented.